like I remember I had a lot of stuff
around money before I had money it was
always like rich people are evil and I
don't know if I do I deserve to ask for
this and that I don't know if I deserve
and explore that look at Louise Hay she
has a great talk about prosperity it's
on like iTunes or whatever look into all
this man because it all needs to be
corrected before you can succeed this is
these people that say money doesn't
bring happiness yeah lies
the blessing of money is not having to
think about money that's it period yes
praise Allah if I fall down the
stairs and I break my ankle I don't have
to go I don't know if I should call the
ambulance that's gonna be you know five
thousand dollars right right yeah right
yeah I could get help right now that's
it yes where I'm at